so another three minute game against
ahmed
2 000 from turkey with a pretty good
rating so let's
let's see what my opponents got up their
sleeve
i'm going to go knight f3 and then i'm
going to promote g3 no matter what
and bishop g2 and castles
and then we start the game okay let me
go d4
and b3 um
the double fianchetto which i think
kramnik may have popularized
i think it was kramek
but i've been wrong before
now either knight d2 or to go for
c4
knight 22 and then e4 or c4 oh god i
will just go cd4
never mind queen c7 preparing e5
rookie 8 feels like over preparation to
me
okay i'll go e4
and then i'll go d5
normally i guess you're not thrilled
about going to e5 in this positions
but i think now the
the queen on c7 looks a bit funny which
may make it justified
also my bishop on b2 is a bit funny so i
don't really know
i'm usually not that great in king's
indian positions
anyway but then again who is
a6 looks a bit weird
i think b5 is not really on the cards
okay let me go rook to c1
obviously if my opponent intends to go
cd5 at some point that brook is going to
be happy
um right there
uh being being activized
okay so bishop g4 is annoying but i
think i'll just go
i think i'll just go f3
because it's annoying in the sense that
[ __ ] b3 can come at some point and then
the bishop might sit on d4
i have a concrete idea in mind which is
exactly this one that after
the very logical bishop d7
b4 seems to trap the knights
and if that is the case that would be
very bad news for for my opponent
cd5 is quite logical
but i think i'll just take back
don't see any problems here
oh i'm so blind
i am so blind i miss knight a4984 bishop
a4
rook c7 i'm using that case
bishop d1 and my queen is not defended
because of that
silly knight on e1 that was really bad i
should just have taken the piece
fortunately he missed it now i'm just
winning
take the knight to move away that was it
no that was
that was less than ideal
try to activate some pieces now
no threats for my opponent as far as i
can see b5 would just prevent
b4
and now if the knight h5
[Music]
do we play actively no we play
technically
knight h5 f5 is just not a threat at all
i think i'll just jump into c6 when i
get the chance not worried about
cycling upon since i'll get a very
strong square for the knight and d5
and probably i will gain control of the
f5
as well i'm also threatening
in some lines to go g4 knight moves and
then f4 could have sex
take back of course
bishop g7
many good moves queen c6 is good also f4
seems a bit more thematic
and g4 that's what i thought
knight on h5 is looking very unfortunate
now
because f3 is the best try to muddy the
waters but i'll i i think i'll just take
it doesn't make a lot of difference
okay um yeah sorry dude it
all hinged on hinged on on one move
there knight e4 but
a4 would have been okay for black the
way it happened
was um was just a loss for my opponent
so
bad luck